so the first one is I just have a quick
one of you just do a quick clap for me
great I have found queer I to be one of
my favorite shows of the year it's got
such an fantastic
feel for outer I think the guys really
care about the people who they're
transforming but it opens up such an
interesting discussion about about
mental health about looking after
yourself self-care and relationships so
to celebrate the second season we were
asked everyone to interview the guys
essentially like the week leading up to
the interview is not that great
personally it was just really hard to
kind of get through it like I'm such a
big fan of a show and I was really
trying to be pumped up for the interview
but I was feeling very very anxious
about meeting them and like screwing it
up essentially we've got one from
Matthew who says vanish then this is not
interior-design level saying I'm a huge
Star Wars fan and right now my room my
apartment looks more like a 14 year old
boy's room rather than an adult
apartment so it started off pretty well
the guys were really nice but I fought
ok just power through these questions
powerful these questions and then we got
to the bits that I was asking Kurama
about self-care and helping yourself and
he was coming back with some really
meaningful advice that actually related
incredibly much to my own personal
situation I had been going through for
the previous few weeks and it really
overly resonated with me so then I was
like oh that was a really good arm for
as you get a note
doesn't mean you're gonna know tomorrow
I'm keeping an over it happened again
later oh and there is a quick question
about relationships this one is quite
sad but hopefully we can find - goodness
- so how do you move on from someone you
love who doesn't love you back
there was another fantastic set of
points made and it felt really personal
even though it was actually somebody
else's problem a better I was like oh my
god this is just so deeply personal all
days another one I'm gonna be writing
down but then I inadvertently blurred
out something like I'm having a [ __ ] mom
now the end of the interview just when
we were wrapping up through all getting
up there but to go cuomo then came over
and was like a you okay and I was like
I'm fine you know I was okay and then
out of nowhere they all initiated a
heart and they all kind of with him
[Music]
and my god it was like the most
unexpected flower motion I've had in
such a long time and I was a bit beside
myself and I didn't kind of know what to
do it was I mean it smelt brilliant it
was fantastic but I was a bit of a mess
to be honest and what queer is so
fantastic at is kind of opening that
discussion about mental health about
being you know caring for people around
you and the fact that it's okay not to
be okay and I think for me that was just
had such an event and resonance
I just didn't necessarily expect and I
think that's
just it was really quite powerful to me
[Music]
you
[Music]